bah je m'appelle cyrille melchior je
suis né à saint pol j'ai grandi à saint
paul
je suis marié père de deux enfants
conseiller départemental
j'ai été aussi et je le suis toujours
conseiller municipal à saint paul mais
le mandat que j'occupais le plus
important c'est celui donc de conseiller
départemental est aujourd'hui j'exerce
donc le mandat de président du conseil
départemental de la réunion il faut
savoir que je suis élu au conseil
départemental
anciennement conseil général depuis
l'année 2000 donc depuis 21 heures
je suis aujourd'hui donc et lucioles
canton 17 comme toujours ma binôme avec
ada l'aude ont donc nous nous sommes
engagés dans ces élections et je tiens
encore remercier toutes les personnes
qui nous ont apporté leur soutien je
suis très attaché à ce quand on pense
que c'est là que je suis né c'est là que
j'ai grandi
j'étais à l'école j'étais au collège au
lycée à saint paul donc mon attachement
est d'abord naturel et bien évidemment
j'apprécie tout ce que je fais pour
cette population très attachante qui
veut que aujourd'hui un enfant de saint
paul et bien travail pour les
saint-polois travail pour la réunion la
confiance qui m'a été donnée
je m'efforce de la rendent à travers
tout ce que je peux faire pour les
saint-polois bien évidemment mais aussi
pour les réunionnais parce que bienvenus
je suis conseiller départemental mais je
le rappelle aussi je suis aussi
président du département de la réunion
donc je dois travailler dans les deux
dimensions au service des saint paulois
mais aussi au service de toute la
population de la réunion
il y a tellement de choses à faire vous
savez que la réunion est devenue
département français il y à 75 ans il y
à toute une période d'évolution qui fait
que notre territoire se développer mais
aujourd'hui ce qui nous préoccupe ce qui
me préoccupe c'est de continuer à
oeuvrer contre la précarité contre la
pauvreté donc en fait à agir dans le
champ de l'action sociale en faveur du
plus grand nombre des familles
réunionnaises qui sont en difficulté au
delà de l'action sociale je travaille
beaucoup aussi sur tout ce qui touche à
la transition écologique parce que vous
voyez tous ces dérèglements climatiques
nous interpelle et nous avons un devoir
j'ai ce devoir en ma qualité de
président du département d'accompagner
le territoire à travers le plan un
million d'arbres transition écologique
faire en sorte que les y aident les
énergies renouvelables soient bien
évidemment utiliser au maximum et
j'accorde aussi beaucoup d'importance à
l'avenir de la jeunesse réunionnaise
cette jeunesse qui nous interpelle qui
est plein de talent qui envient beaucoup
de volonté pour aller de l'avant et bien
le département doit agir pour
accompagner cette jeunesse faire une
association durable c'est là aussi une
priorité forte et je dirais avant de
terminer que nous avons la sécurité
alimentaire faire en sorte que le
territoire de la réunion est bien plus
aller le plus loin possible en matière
de production agricole une agriculture
raisonnée et navigateurs de qualité une
agriculture qui sera capable de fournir
des produits pays pour le plus grand
nombre des réunionnaises et réunionnais
le département le conseil départemental
c'est l'assemblée qui travaille au
service de l'humain de la promotion
sociale de la promotion de l'homme et de
la femme réunionnaise et mon devoir là
aussi en ma qualité de président c'est
de rassembler les énergies de fédérer
les énergies les bonnes volontés pour
avoir le meilleur projet au service de
la population et nous travaillons à
mettre en place un projet de mandature
qui associés les membres de la majorité
comme les autres personnes élus au
département parce que je compte je
considère que l'assemblée départementale
forme à tous il n'y a pas forcément une
opposition une majorité il ya des élus
qui s'engagent et ma méthode c'est donc
de travailler ensemble je le dis
toujours à la réunion nos ancêtres nos
anciens nous ont appris à vivre ensemble
à bien vivre ensemble mais aujourd'hui
nous devons aussi travailler ensemble
cela c'est ma méthode et au département
je dirais que nous devons être
exemplaires dans ce domaine a dû
travailler ensemble c'est ma méthode et
c'est de cette façon que nous avançons